[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de Francia 24 no
son niñas son madres así fue bautizada
la campaña regional que busca luchar a
través de un podcast en las principales
plataformas contra el embarazo infantil
y poder Mostrar las condiciones de abuso
que rodean a América Latina el fondo de
población de las Naciones Unidas alerta
que esta región es la única del mundo en
la cual los partos en niñas menores de
15 años siguen en aumento Colombia en
2021 cada día registró 46 casos de
violencia sexual contra niños o en niñas
y adolescentes en Ecuador cada día se
reciben 11 denuncias por violación y 10
corresponden a niñas menores de 14 años
en Paraguay dos niñas de Entre 10 y 14
años se convierten en madres cada día en
Nicaragua se calcula que cada día al
menos cinco niñas son obligadas a ser
madres y las cifras siguen a ese ritmo
en los países latinos
Esta es una iniciativa de al menos una
de organizaciones de lucha por los
derechos de las mujeres una de ellas es
el centro de derechos reproductivos y
por eso nos acompaña la abogada
Alejandra magistra en estudios de género
y consultora en derechos humanos
Alejandra gracias a usted debe por estar
en ella soy y las cifras son simplemente
alarmantes ustedes lo dicen América
Latina es la única Región del mundo en
la cual los partos en menores de 15 años
siguen en aumento porque
Hola Muchísimas gracias por la
invitación y saludar a todas las
personas que te escuchan mira aquí tiene
que ver con una falta de una política de
salud sexual y educación sexual integral
información y sobre todo que las menores
las adolescentes vivan libres de
violencias las cifras muchas de esas
cifras de embarazadas adolescentes están
muy conectadas con violencia el 80% de
las violaciones en la región son sobre
menores de 14 años y eso nos tiene que
llamar la atención muchos de estos
embarazos son violentos y muchas veces
ponen en riesgo a la salud de las niñas
entonces hay como una suerte de
elementos que se conjugan falta de
Educación un entorno violento que ya van
a que tengamos las cifras que
mencionaste Bueno hablemos ahora de lo
que pasa con esas niñas que después se
vuelven forzosamente madres hay impactos
físicos a impactos psicológicos a
impactos sociales en el mejor de los
casos Si sobreviven al parto
exactamente y su proyecto de vida nunca
vuelve a ser el mismo Además porque la
mayoría de Estados no tienen políticas
serias de acompañamiento después de que
ellas tienen su parto es decir hay un
círculo que las encierra no les dan
educación sexual integral no les dan
acceso aborto cuando quedan embarazadas
de forma violenta o incluso no Y luego
el estado tampoco las acompaña en ese
proceso de hacerse cargo digamos así de
un niño una niña cuando tiene el parto
Entonces es algo que impacta su proyecto
de vida profundamente muchas dejan sus
estudios por ejemplo muchas tienen que
empezar a hacer trabajo desde muy
temprana edad entonces para sostener a
su hijo o a su hija y algunas incluso
pues empiezan también estar en círculos
de violencia económica también producto
de la necesidad de obtener recursos hay
que recordar que vivimos en menos las
regiones más empobrecidas digamos así
del mundo y que esto es muy importante
también tenerlo en cuenta para ver
cuáles son las condiciones de vida de
estas niñas a las que se les obliga a
ser madres y estamos hablando ahí Además
del proyecto de vida de esa niña pero
qué va en un futuro no tan lejano con
ese bebé que se está criando finalmente
estamos hablando de niñas criando bebés
exactamente y de círculos de pobreza que
se terminan reforzando porque son niños
y niñas que nacen en entornos muchas
veces violentos entornos que no están
preparados para cuidarles adecuadamente
y vuelvo insisto en estados que no son
responsables en estados que de ninguna
manera atienden las necesidades de estos
niños y niñas y que les proveen
seguridad social acceso a educación
acceso alimentación digna por eso
también tenemos unos datos alarmantes
por ejemplo de hambre infantil en
nuestro continente y eso también muchos
de estos niños que están apareciendo
hambre son hijos de adolescentes que no
tienen apoyo Estatal para sostenerlos y
que en su momento tampoco tuvieron mi
acceso información para prevenir el
embarazo en entornos no violentos y
tampoco acceso aborto mire Alejandra
alguno de los argumentos que utilizan
los movimientos que se hacen Llamar
provida es precisamente ese no la
protección de la vida A toda Costa y por
eso un poco confrontando ese argumento
Yo quiero preguntarle Cuáles son los
efectos físicos en el cuerpo de una niña
que se convirtió en madre
Hay muchísimas cada cuerpo es totalmente
diferente Pero la ciencia documentado
que cuando tú tienes un parto antes de
tus 18 años hay un montón de efectos
físicos en cambios hormonales además de
esto también hay cambios en tu sistema
reproductivo y hay digamos así tampoco
tu madurez emocionales es sí por digamos
las está totalmente desarrollada para
ejecutar la labor de crianza que es
absolutamente importante si hay muchos
cambios en sus cuerpos que muchas veces
no son capaces y tampoco se les asesora
para entenderlo yo vuelvo y te insisten
que hay unos ciclos viciosos digamos Así
que encierran a las niñas en una un
canal de violación a derechos humanos no
hay educación sexual integral no hay
acceso aborto ni anticonceptivos en
muchos países son costosos y después del
19 en esta región está todavía más
empobrecida y tampoco hay acompañamiento
Estatal profundo de alguna manera en los
momentos en que ellas lo requieren
Entonces los efectos en sus cuerpos son
importantes pero son aún más impactantes
los impactos en su proyecto de vida que
no pueden tienen que aceptar trabajos
mal remunerados muchas veces caen en
redes de explotación y de trata porque
necesitan sobrevivir y necesitan también
sostener una nueva vida y frente al
argumento que tú mencionas de defensa de
la vida Simplemente como existencia
biológica lo que nosotros manifestamos
es que hay que defender la vida por
supuesto y la vida prenatal también pero
hay que hacerlo pensando una vida en
condiciones dignas no en cualquier tipo
de condición y pensar en un proceso que
nos acompaña desde el estado todo el
proceso gestacional y que siempre sea
voluntario y en una edad en donde la
persona esté preparada para asumirla
mire aquí siempre lo decimos en ella soy
la maternidad tiene que ser deseada hace
un momento cuando usted hablaba
Alejandra detrás de ustedes en nuestra
pantalla aparecían las imágenes del
sitio web que ustedes habilitaron para
hablar de este tema niñas no madres ese
punto o hereje y aquí está toda la
información pero quisiera que usted nos
cuente porque un podcast Cuántos
capítulos donde se puede ver y pues de
qué van a hablar en qué nos pueden
educar
ustedes se pueden encontrar en niñas no
madres.com que es el espacio ustedes
pueden encontrar allí las historias en
primera persona de las niñas a las
cuales se les ha obligado a la
maternidad Y creo que eso es lo más
bonito de este espacio son ellas mismas
contando sus historias no son
profesionales expertos en el tema sino
ellas mismas contándoles los impactos en
primera persona que han vivido en este
momento lo pueden encontrar ahí en la
página y la motivación que tuvimos para
crearlo fue poner en primer plano las
voces de ellas y para que la gente que
muchas veces no no siente cercanía
digamos la psico Las investigaciones que
hacemos desde el movimiento feminista lo
vea en primera persona desde ellos allí
También este podcast también surgió de
la idea de un litigio que tenemos de
cuatro casos ante el comité de derechos
humanos de Naciones Unidas en donde
llevamos cosas de cuatro niñas de países
diferentes de Guatemala Ecuador y
Nicaragua también hay un caso peruano en
donde llevamos el comité de Derechos
Humanos estos casos para mostrar los
impactos en las vías de ellas por haber
sido obligadas a tener un parto antes de
18 años todas en nuestros casos parieron
antes de los 14 y en el podcast ustedes
van a poder escuchar sus historias de
vida Cuáles son los impactos en la
práctica y creamos la campaña en niñas
no madres para que la gente entienda que
esto lo normalizamos mucho en nuestro
continente se volvió parte del paisaje
tener menores de 14 teniendo partos y
criando y educando y la gente no
dimensiona lo que esto implica y el
podcast tiene ese objetivo queremos que
la gente se acerque a esa realidad
usted lo estaba diciendo y es que en
muchos círculos sociales de lo que se
habla es de mamás jóvenes de mujeres que
llegaron la de la maternidad siendo
siendo siendo muy pequeñas o muy jóvenes
pero no se habla de embarazo infantil y
más allá de eso no se habla de abuso
infantil entonces aquí mi siguiente
Pregunta para ustedes Alejandra es
pidiéndole que nos aclare
Por qué Y cuando un embarazo es un abuso
sexual o producto de un abuso sexual
cuando estamos hablando de menores
siempre que no haya consentimiento y en
algunos países incluso cualquier tipo de
contacto sexual antes de los 14 años es
delito para el consentimiento es el
elemento central y casi siempre las
relaciones con menores de edad hay un
elemento de poder un desequilibrio de
poder en donde ellas no pueden darse
consentimiento de manera plena libre e
informada Generalmente hay presiones por
ejemplo en el caso los casos que yo te
mencionaba que estamos llevando ante el
comité de Derechos Humanos son casos en
donde ellas todas tenían menos de 14
años y su agresor era alguien que tenía
una posición de poder sobre ella un
funcionario público su papá su abuelo en
fin como personas que tienen situaciones
de poder nosotros tenemos un gran
problema en nuestra continente y es que
tenemos un contexto muy violento con las
niñas a violencia sexual contra las
niñas están muy normalizada las
relaciones con grandes digamos gaps de
edad están muy normalizadas Y eso tiene
grandísimos problemas porque se quedan
relaciones desequilibradas en donde
Generalmente hay violencia sexual de por
medio donde las chicas no pueden emitir
su consentimiento y esto lo hemos
normalizado a sí mismo
cómo normalizando estas maternidades que
se han denominado inadecuadamente
simplemente maternidades tempranas e
incluso están tristes decir lo que te va
a contar hay las políticas públicas
aparecen de esta manera los estados
preven que esto va a pasar y en vez de
evitarlo simplemente lo tienen dentro de
la estadística como va a ocurrir
simplemente vamos a tener a niñas a
menores de 14 pariendo Y ya y lo
catalogan como embarazos tempranos pero
en muchos países este incluso Es delito
en el caso de Colombia que es desde
donde te estoy hablando en este momento
cualquier contacto sexual con menor de
14 años es un delito y aún así en los
hospitales se normalizan los partos en
esas edades eso es muy compleja la
situación y sigue pasando ya para mi
última pregunta Alejandra pues mire la
idea de podcast es muy interesante para
las comunidades que tienen acceso a
internet que tienen acceso a un celular
y sobre todo pues para los grupos
poblacionales que tienen una educación
previa y acceso simplemente acceso y
privilegio Pero qué pasa con las
comunidades más vulnerables que son
donde más se presentan este tipo de
casos y pues yo no sé si van a tener un
podcast
efectivamente nosotros lo que estamos
intentando también es mezclar las
estrategias para que arrancamos con un
podcast y luego esto se convierta en
otros medios de comunicación que le
lleguen a todos los sectores nosotras
hacen lo mucho litigamos un caso que fue
el caso Paola Guzmán albarracín contra
Ecuador donde también allí que es un
caso ante la Corte Interamericana Y
aunque haya sido un caso contra Ecuador
su presidente opera para todo el
continente donde también le pedimos que
se cree a la Corte Interamericana que se
crea un estándar para que este tipo de
información Se difunda en todos los
medios públicos radio que también lo
usan mucho personas vemos la si todavía
y otro tipo de medios que le puedan
llegar a las personas que se haga
difusión en redes sociales y en otros
medios de toda la información sobre
embarazo adolescente prevención de la
violencia sexual es parte de lo que
nosotros le estamos pidiendo también al
comité de Derechos Humanos en los casos
que estamos litigando estamos pidiendo
siempre que haya otros medios para que
la gente más allá de un podcast nosotros
estamos simplemente empezando y de como
organización de la sociedad civil
poniendo nuestro gra arena pero es
obligación de los estados estamos
litigando para que los estados puedan
poner esta información a disposición de
todo el mundo en todos los medios que la
gente pueda leer puede haber periódicos
radio y eso es muy importante tu
reflexión es muy importante porque
efectivamente los podcast son un medio
de muy poca gente todavía revisa como sé
que son relativamente nuevos se quiere
decir pero estamos trabajando a través
de litigio para obligar a los Estados a
que esta información que es tan
importante la difundan por otros medios
pues viene Muchísimas gracias Alejandra
ya nos quedamos sin tiempo pero el
agradecimiento para usted y pues al
centro de derechos reproductivos por
participar de esta conversación y a
nuestros televidentes nos vemos
Próximamente en ellas hoy y por favor
recuerden los embarazos las maternidades
deben ser deseadas y también deben ser
consentidas gracias
[Música]